[موسيقى]
يعني من الساعه تقريبا
سبع كده نصحى خلاص ما ننام الا الساعه
تقريبا 11 بالليل
[موسيقى]
قعدنا ندوره حصلنا جزيره هذه يعني نسبه
الاسلام عندهم 98
هناك رحنا وصلنا الجزيره
يعني جزيره مره حلوه استانس على هلا جزيره
طيبتهم واسلوبهم
فقلت للشباب انا ايش رايكم نسوي افطار صعب
يكون
[موسيقى]
يوميا نحضر وجبات تقريبا كل وجبه يوصل
عددهن اللي هو 1100 وجبه القريه فهل
القريه يصير هذا يوم عندهم عيد
لانه يعني صعب ان يكون اللحم فما عنده
استطاعه يشترون اللحم فتشوفيه اذا وصلنا
عندهم يطلعوا لنا الحريم النساء ياخذون في
البصل وياخذون
الخضار يقطعون الخضار معانا يساعدونا
يشتغلون يعني بحب
[موسيقى]
انا لازم اي قريه اروح لامها لازم اسوي
بصمه
رسالتي انا مو لازم مال علشان تصدق
اقدر تصدق يعني وابتسامه
لطف مع الاطفال لطف مع الناس مو مجرد انا
عندي مال اطعم
مسكين لا اله هذا غلط
فقير ترى
ابتسامه افضل وابتسامه من غني بسبب
[موسيقى]